all right we've been talking about the
Senate vote or possible vote on version
two of the Republican slash Trump
American Health Care Act this is the
Republican and Trump led initiative to
repeal Obamacare the Affordable Care Act
and put in place something else we have
been waiting for the Congressional
Budget Office a nonpartisan agency that
scores and evaluates government
proposals we've been waiting for their
scoring of the Senate version two of the
American Health Care Act I'll remind you
that House version two of the American
Health Care Act was scored by the CBO as
leading to 23 million additional
uninsured individuals we now have the
numbers from Senate version two of the
American Health Care Act and it would
lead to twenty two million people losing
insurance it would also reduce the
deficit by three hundred and twenty-one
billion dollars over ten years
this is not a lot I hate to break it to
the so-called fiscal conservatives but
thirty two point 1 billion dollars per
year is a pretty damn small amount
particularly when it doesn't even
consider the costs of the externalities
of people not having health insurance as
far as premiums premiums are expected to
fall in 2026 nearly 10 years from now
after initially rising that is an almost
worthless part of the prediction it's
very difficult to predict think about
health insurance premiums first of all
always go up its moral question of how
much not if they will go up and to
predict how much they will go up or or
drop over a nearly ten year period is
very difficult to predict and it will be
impacted by other forces impacting upon
that we can't really gather much from
that for Republicans it was never about
insuring the most amount of people
possible now it was about lowering
premiums for the average American so if
there's really no evidence that it would
even do that you can see why even folks
on the right like Ted Cruz and Mike Lee
are not supporting this because it
really doesn't get to the root of the
issue well it's a disastrous bill right
the root of the issue would be Trump
said we're going to
this beautiful plan and it will be
cheaper and more people will be covered
and nobody will die bla bla bla bla bla
people will die and earlier on CNN I
watched Kate Baldwin call a
congresswoman Jackie Speier hyperbolic
for saying that this will definitely
lead to people dying if 22 million fewer
people have health insurance we can't
say which of those 22 million people
will die due to not having care but some
of those 22 million people will
absolutely die from not having care this
bill would also eliminate the mandates
which require nearly everyone to have
coverage as well as companies with over
50 employees need to provide at least
some health benefits that's gone it
would eliminate Obamacare taxes on the
wealthy as well as insurers you need
that in order to pay for this entire
system that we have because it's such a
horrible system to begin with but it
would maintain much of Obamacare subsidy
structure to help poor people pay for
individual coverage but it will be way
less generous particularly for older
employees as an example older and
lower-income enrollees would be hit
harder by the Republican plan the CBO
analysis says that a sixty four-year-old
with an income of fifty-six thousand
dollars would pay sixty eight hundred
dollars for a silver plan under the
current law already outrageous by the
way but that same individual could pay
up to twenty thousand five hundred
dollars for an identical plan if this
Senate bill were to pass this is an
absolute and total disaster and as an
interesting note according to the CBO
four million people would lose
employer-provided coverage next year
this whole thing that we hear from the
right about listen if you get a job you
don't have to worry about it you're
going to have insurance that's also BS
according to the CBO four of the 22
million people that will lose coverage
will have jobs and still won't have
insurance I think the most cohesive
strategy for Democrats to take is that
people will die because they don't have
access to health insurance under this
plan and the Center for American
Progress which is admittedly a left wing
think-tank survey estimates that 17,000
people will die next year at this one
to pass and by 2026 it will be an
estimated 28,000 per year I've heard
numbers anywhere from 20 up to 60,000
people that we could reasonably expect
to die as a result of this Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell wants a
vote this week before legislators leave
town for the 4th of July holiday there
are 52 Republican senators you need 52
vote YES to get this through the Senate
five Republicans have already said we're
not going to support this in its current
form senator Susan Collins of Maine is
one of those people she has a lot of
seniors in her state
this may already be dead and and you
know what this I've been talking about
this for years you can't start with
Obamacare and move to the right and not
hurt people because after all Obamacare
is pretty damn right-wing it's an idea
that was come up with it was conceived
initially by a right-wing think-tank in
the 1990s there is no way that you could
start with Obamacare and say we're going
to make this more quote conservative
really reactionary is what it is and
cover more people for less with better
health outcomes you just can't do it
right I mean I think the approach is to
take away the Medicaid expansion it's to
get rid of a lot of the subsidies and
who's going to be in support of that
it's a happy that we would leave up the
someone wrote to me saying this is
almost Malthusian to support this you
have to believe the hype the Furies of
Malthus which suggested that the
carrying capacity for the Earth's
population is uh it will eventually it
be exceeded by that population growth
and the only way to adjust for that and
every once in a while you need either
famine or natural disaster or some way
of trimming the population only if you
believe something like that could you
possibly support this unless you're just
clueless like many of these Republicans
are we'll see if we get that vote we'll
see what ultimately happens hopefully
it's dead in the water already if indeed
five Republican senators are not going
to vote for